des travaux sont actuellement en cours
de réalisation sur la route
départementale 41
un chantier de sécurisation de la route
de la montagne contre les risques de
chutes de pierres
le projet consiste donc à mettre en
place un grillage par éboulis plaqué au
rocher cette route quand elles
constituent un itinéraire stratégique et
ical et construite à flanc de falaise
sur une bonne partie de l'itinéraire les
soumis à des risques importants
d'érosion qui nous qui oblige le
département à l'entretenir et de prévoir
un budget conséquent qui est en moyenne
depuis les cinq dernières années de
l'ordre de 250 mille euros par an rien
que pour la sécurisation de l'itinéraire
en faisant des travaux de confortement
des falaises en amont mais aussi bien
bien entendu des travaux d'affaissement
en dessous des routes
les travaux consistent en une étude de
la fracturation et un relevé des
instabilités ses études permettent de
déterminer les zones à purger ainsi que
de dimensionner les ancrages la mise en
oeuvre nécessite les services
d'entreprises spécialisées dans les
travaux acrobatiques
elle comprend plusieurs étapes mois déjà
il faut nettoyer le talus et clairement
donc on débroussaille on arrête toute la
végétation
ça nous permet déjà d'avoir une bonne
expertise on voit un petit peu mieux le
rocher l'état du caillou comment il est
d'élite et à partir de là on peut
engager les travaux de purge pour
enlever tous les matériaux un petit peu
instable une fois que ces purges et à ce
moment là on peut commencer à faire des
ancrages de maintien qui vont servir à
tenir la couverture grillage et qu'on va
poser par la suite la pose des filets ou
des grillages s'effectue depuis le haut
du versant en fonction de
l'accessibilité il faut envisager
d'avoir recours à un hélicoptère
cette solution non sans risques permet
d'accélérer
la pause 35 à 40 pour nos peuvent alors
être placé en une heure
bon voila moi c'est de préparer la
journée le moment le moment propice pour
le pôle héliportage parce qu'il lui
quand il vient cessé d'être un moment
cours dans un bref délai donc on doit on
a peu parlé
le matériel les outils la zone
d'évolution pour que tout se fasse
combiné menti au départ dans la sécurité
dans les meilleurs cas des cas pour tout
le personnel comme pour le personnel de
la durée de vie de ce type de parade et
estimé à plusieurs décennies
la rupture de certains éléments
n'entraîne pas systématiquement la
destruction du dispositif les ligatures
émail défectueuse doivent être réparée
dès la constatation des dégâts en
contrôle périodique de par conséquent
être effectué un grillage qui est double
torsion ski c'est double torsion permet
d'éviter que s'il ya une coupure d'un
morceau du grillage que tout s'effiloche
c'est à dire si vous coupez la le
grillage garde toute son intégrité et ça
arrive de temps en temps lorsqu'il ya
des chutes de pia avec une grande
vitesse qui arrive sur du grillage
cervelle que ça découpe une partie du
grillage ça ne met pas du tout en
paierez l'ouvragé il suffit après de
rajouter une petite surface
supplémentaire pour pour le réparer un
grillage qui peut être entretenues si
jamais quand même sur certaines poches
il y avait des blocs qui viendraient
être bloqué derrière le grillage on peut
facilement dévissé l'écrou enlever la
plaque soulager un peu la tension du
câble de pied est enlevé à vider la
poche et leurs maîtres
le conseil départemental met un point
d'honneur à sécuriser la route de la
montagne
en effet la rd41 est un itinéraire
historique qui permet de relier le nord
à l'ouest
chaque jour c'est près de dix mille
usagers qui empruntent cette route